foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is the break room the daily live uh
show we're broadcasting from new
rockstars uh home studio here in
beautiful Los Angeles California and uh
we got a lot to talk about today some uh
Spider-Man news of course that's in the
thumbnail in the title that's probably
why you came here but also we got spawn
news Barry kyogan is that all you say
his last name
very foreign last name is uh is thirsty
out there uh we and then a little bit of
werewolf by night uh teasing Jay was
just uh teasing us right before we
started with his impressions of that
film I won't spoil any of those uh but
speaking of which we've got Jay
Washington here with us
let me tell you something I've been
waiting to be on this show since they
started and what the funny thing was
they all kept thinking I was in Chicago
and I was like I'm always saying I'm in
La I'm like I represent home but I'm
here and y'all family
Chicago on the show because we know
you're from there but we talked trash on
New Jersey
and just New Jersey uh yeah sure yeah I
don't know whatever we'll make some
differences
[Laughter]
make sure that means out of Chatsworth
before the day is done Canoga Park
you'll catch it that's right that's
right uh Pomona be on watch uh We've
also got Jessica Clemons and Tommy
Bechtel hey everybody I want a shot on
our fans in Alabama Alaska Arizona
Arkansas California Colorado Connecticut
Delaware Florida Georgia Hawaii Idaho
Illinois Indiana Iowa Kansas Kentucky
Louisiana Maine Maryland Massachusetts
Michigan Minnesota Mississippi Missouri
Montana Nebraska Nevada New Hampshire
New Mexico
North Dakota Ohio Oklahoma Oregon
Pennsylvania Rhode Island South Carolina
South Dakota Tennessee Texas Utah
Vermont Virginia Washington West
Virginia Wisconsin Wyoming all of those
people wow he was beat as a kid if he
could get those right yeah
49 states uh all 49 both New Jersey and
um Puerto Rico should be pretty offended
right now uh getting getting skipped
also we're going to talk a little bit of
She-Hulk that episode's coming out
tonight
um thank you to everybody that's already
in the chat and joining us live uh for
super chat today for every hundred
dollars and already Corey uh can drilly
um putting some shame on uh the New
Jersey name uh for every hundred dollars
it will trigger a rant from one person
here on on the panel uh you know
whatever is is bugging them is boiling
to the surface it needs to be expelled
live on the air we'll give you a little
taste right now oh no tell me
I want to talk about the McDonald's
chicken sandwich
sometimes you get the McDonald's chicken
sandwich and it's delicious it comes in
a foil bag with pickles and the sauce
it's so tasty other times you get it and
it tastes like somebody just cooked up a
piece of foam from a yoga mat it's so
chewy there's no part of a chicken I
know that that comes from so I want to
say to you McDonald's do better
do better
you're good half the time
uh all right let's let's get to some
headlines look at some headlines there's
our graphic okay great a nice wonderful
uh array of diverse headlines today
different nerdy properties uh spawn
there's a spawn movie in development at
uh Bloom house Blum House they brought
us um the uh uh Purge movies and The
Invisible Woman movie with Elizabeth
Moss they've done a lot of cool work
mostly in horror but they're working on
a spawn movie that has Jamie Foxx
attached and it just got a couple
writers attached to it including uh
Scott silver who co-wrote Joker uh
Malcolm Spellman who was the writer and
showrunner of Falcon Winter Soldier and
is working on the uh Captain America New
World Order script and uh Matt Mixon
there's a kind of an up and coming
um writer so uh that thing's moving
forward
can I ask a question yes do can we can
we agree right now that Jamie Foxx is
just going to be Jamie Foxx again yeah
like because he doesn't see he always
will say he goes out of character but
remember Jamie Foxx's Electro was just
it's Jimmy it's Jamie Foxx Jamie even
when he was Jamie Foxx with The Gap it
was just Jamie Foxx so like him trying
to take over Michael Jai White's role is
gonna be like all right bro I just seen
you do this now you just got on Freddy
Krueger prosthesis like that's it yeah I
didn't see the uh the Vampire movie he
just did on Netflix
like one of those things you're like we
want to be optimistic yeah the spawn
franchise is obviously one of the most
influential Comics franchise the last 30
years
um there's certainly those those Michael
Jai White films John Leguizamo doing
weird crouchy uh clown work uh yeah they
they hold a place in any 90s kids heart
um so we're optimistic here and with
those talented writers I mean I don't
think there's a director yet so we'll
see we'll see maybe uh Brandon will get
it Brandon threw his hat in the ring for
a few movies Brandon Barrick yeah uh
yeah he's somewhere on the list a little
bit near the bottom but um speaking of
uh relaunched franchises yes uh we're
anticipating getting a Super Mario I
think Charlie Day confirmed it oh he's a
trailer on the Nintendo Direct tomorrow
okay
yeah you gotta watch it on Nintendo
Direct so if you haven't paid your
subscription time to get back in there
this is it live action or animated it's
animated wait
the detail of the antique shop with the
old 8-bit uh and 16-bit Mario elements
is wonderful okay so this is nothing
it's like the 90s one yes what's that I
said this is nothing like the 90s one I
don't know I was thinking of like was on
my own uh that was another one in the
90s I was born in the 70s if we say like
with Zama one more time on this show he
appears
um in other news that's a pet
in other news uh
um this is blowing up the internet a
little bit uh velma's gay
whoa that's water is wet news that is
also true we were I think that's also
why they did it for this movie is
because we as fans have been saying it
since we first saw Velma that we're like
we know she's bi we know she's queer we
know something and then they're like
finally like we're gonna do Bert and
Ernie stuff set me up with that one
again give me the headlines
velma's gay Robert's right
[Music]
now is this what is this this is For an
upcoming Scooby-Doo film yeah it's for
the news no but not that this is it's
just a general election
but also wasn't there just a Scooby-Doo
movie that was canceled
action when it was a live-action
animated hybrid this is just a fully
animated one got it well Velma sees a
thick cute chocolate sugar she's like
I'm writing that Queen is this the Velma
movie no this is a regular oh because
there's a Velma movie Mindy Kaling is
this isn't it this is different that
moment is still canonically heterosexual
I don't know I'm just wondering if I got
a chance which Velma I got a chance
I know they're all cartoons but I am
planning on uploading my comments uh the
velmas you might have a chance would be
at uh Comic Cons okay and the cosplay
and then there's Hollywood no I can't go
to any of those anymore
I brought in too many knives last time
okay I was playing Gordon Ramsay okay
cosplaying
games it's super popular uh cosplay uh
speaking of things that are slightly off
brand for us uh we're getting a uh Blues
Clues movie trailer yeah we already
dated trailer came out yesterday for the
Blues Clues movie they kind of has this
will be the connection to today's
episode there's a bit of a Multiverse
angle all the different Steves are
showing up no way home but Blue's Clues
with all the different Steves so we got
so we cry every time go up to school I
already cried at the trailer because it
opens with spoiler Steve going I haven't
seen you in years and I go
but who is he talking about is it gave
Elmo
no we don't uh we can stay on this one
okay so uh it's coming up this Friday
and we're doing a special episode of the
break room around werewolf by night
because that's coming out and now when
we say it comes out Friday does that
mean it comes out Thursday at midnight I
sure hope so because I'm staying up all
night
Friday Junior so that is yeah Friday
June the beginning of Friday and so we
will have watched it for the Friday
break room uh we hope you the audience
will have on some time to uh to join us
because we'll be celebrating this film a
lot of press has been going on for World
by Night director Michael giacchino uh
who's done a lot of great composing work
in the MCU and in other places
um but he did he had a couple great
quotes that we liked he was talking
about uh the presence of monsters in
this movie we know man thing's going to
be in there some other obviously a
werewolf some of the monsters
um Jay is uh holding back he has very
strong positive thoughts about this film
and maybe someone doesn't come out it is
great but Michael giacino said that like
I I really like this quote he was like
too often even in Marvel movies you know
the monsters are just something to kill
it's just like uh you know uh uh an NPC
or whatever right like a gross thing
that the hero needs to kill and he's
like no monsters are are nothing but a
person with a problem who can't solve it
and needs help solving it everything I
loved as a kid about these films is that
they were allegories for people with
afflictions that need help
um I love that as a metaphor I love it
right and even we've seen that in lots
of different horror movies right like
it's the monster's Looking For Love or
good connection or maybe like vampirism
as a metaphor for STDs or I don't know
you know there's a lot of different
you're talking about it follows because
that's my favorite for sure or a heart
or courage or a brain that's not a
horror movie
and that is a horror movie for sure yeah
I know you're scared that's the actors
okay they all got sick okay from the
makeup from the puppies
they were they were putting it in the
soda back then um and then he went on to
say that um Uh Kevin feige actually
pitched man thing being in the film and
uh giacino was like oh that added a lot
of pressure having this great character
man thing and uh Elsa Bloodstone in it
he's like oh okay now that these great
Comics characters gonna be in this okay
there's a little bit more pressure to
make this great which according to Jay
he delivered yeah because again I was
saying this early before we went live
and I've been telling different people
this Marvel has been in there yo let's
give you these obscure characters back
and they've made it work the recent
episode of She-Hulk they pulled out
porcupine they pulled out man Bull and
people were like wait who are these
characters
so I had actually seen Nathan in the
costume back in February oh yeah he
because he showed it to me and he was
like you can't tell nobody I see a lot
of know a lot of stuff about happening
in the MCU I'm not talking nope don't
give me that black woman look she gave
me that sister looked like why you ain't
telling me nothing I had no idea that
that was Nathan heard because of the
makeup I didn't even recognize his voice
I don't know why I think it's just
because it was so crazy looking but yeah
it was like he told me he showed it to
me he was like he didn't know fully he
couldn't remember what episode it was
and I was like this is dope he was like
yeah I'm on Seahawk and I was like okay
so now you make like the eighth friend I
have in the MCU and I'm trying to be the
ninth one of my nine friends there you
go because like you got to be friends
with yourself man that's what I'm trying
to do now thank you for therapy but uh
but in general though with the
characters they've been bringing in in
just this phase alone it's those obscure
comic book characters that people the
average fan doesn't know and so bringing
in man thing yeah there are comic book
fans of man thing but when you see man
thinking this one you're gonna be like
oh oh oh okay I said nothing else oh my
God I said nothing else again nothing
but good things about werewolf by night
everybody mark your calendars we're
watching it uh uh we'll be talking about
it Friday I guess one question oh yeah
if you are afraid of horror movies
should you be watching it oh it's
Halloween watch that movie yeah come on
I'm afraid of horror movies I'm gonna
watch this is a [ __ ] that's the thing
too and I've said this and everybody
else whose reviews have said this pretty
much this is a horror movie that you do
not believe that Marvel was able to make
like with everything we've seen you know
the action levels are one thing but what
they do in where will but not you're
like oh they preparing you for a bunch
of stuff going forward they're like
we're gonna let violence happen now
because it gets violent
it gets so violent it's like kind of
what Star Wars is doing with Andor where
they're like you know this show might be
a little more violent than you're used
to pushing the boundaries of that tv-14
rating on Disney plus absolutely
um sorry there you go okay we are we
we're gonna have a special episode on
Friday for werewolf by night I'm gonna
have to drink a lot of G film I'm gonna
mix a bunch of flavors together so I can
stay up all night don't do that now
you're just gonna combine price and
portal fluids and pineapple mix them all
up and I'll say all night and watch a
scary movie watch out to say a prayer
for Tommy's Soul because I don't know
it's gonna make it and his heart
primarily say a prayer for my soul say a
prayer for my whole cause I'm going G
fuel all night
okay he invited Jay for the first time
and I said we are going to be good I
said we are going to be appropriate I've
known Jay for a while okay yeah
appropriate is not in time Jay's
experienced this before he's not in a
public setting uh speaking of uh public
setting we did get a teaser clip of
course the next episode of She-Hulk the
penultimate episode right there's just
two left yes this is yeah there will be
one left after this yes the episodes are
coming out tonight we got a little
teaser clip uh that features uh LeapFrog
and you know some other guy from Marvel
uh people have probably heard about it
um I think we have a shortened version
of that clip to roll now John but my
name is LeapFrog yes that has been noted
several times Mr patilia cool so your
defective suit
you need to back off and waste this
outfit Eugene get out of here
you're making a mistake you made a
mistake when you messed with my clients
oh you don't even know Mt immediately
went off on Twitter he went off on
Instagram he went off on Twitter he
texted us he was like oh my
God noted LeapFrog fans now it feels
like maybe because they also came out
with a lot of uh other like little
videos for elite frag appearing like the
audition tape between like Mark Ruffalo
and Tatiana mazlani uh and Ginger
Gonzaga and I'm like they waited to see
how important he was going to be to the
fans and then they released this like
extra clip of LeapFrog and I think Mt is
that fan like specifically for him micro
targeted now Brandon Stanley are the guy
that plays LeapFrog talks to Mt they are
now friends
all right it's like it's his number one
fan and he's so excited he's kind of
sweet and we've known from the earliest
promos that uh
uh Daredevil's gonna appear in in
She-Hulk obviously we've been waiting
each week we're like is this the week is
this week confirmed tonight Daredevil
makes his appearance and Matt Murdock
well we I guess we we've already gotten
a little bit of that but um yeah so uh
very excited for to see the entirety of
that action sequence me too I didn't
expect them to both come in on like the
same episode and just be so important to
each other I'm so glad they held it this
low because everybody thought everybody
thought you were getting Daredevil come
like episode two and then four you
didn't get anything then when you
finally got the helmet you were like oh
he's got to be in the next episode oh
he's not and they waited because what
they did and this is smart if you give
Daredevil away early people think he's
in the whole show right and people have
to remember this isn't his show he has a
he has a full TV season about to happen
Okay 18 episodes yeah very long the full
TV season so he's just enough to be this
canon in there because he's a lawyer
she's a lawyer she gets her suit he
makes a new suit boom yeah I love it I'm
obsessed with it I can't wait to see
what tonight's episode is I know we're
very we're very excited we've been
enjoying the whole season and clearly
like these last two episodes you know we
have some lingering questions we would
like answered some other stuff Tommy a
little bit later is going to be doing uh
predictions for this episode uh running
those as he's been running everything
directly into the ground
God damn yeah
is fair you know what I'm nothing if not
fair okay uh announcement for our
discussion our thumbnail discussion you
guys so the Spider-Man actor Jacob
battle Babylon why are you looking at me
and I don't speak anymore all right well
he plays Ned he plays Ned in the
Spider-Man uh Tom Holland Spider-Man's
uh he casts his own doubts to coming
back to the future of Spider-Man
projects so in an interview he says uh
when asked about his future in
Spider-Man he says I feel like actors
are the last people to know I think that
people assume that actors are always
hiding Secrets I promise you we don't
know anything which we do know but we uh
but again if it's the right place at the
right time with the right group of
people and we've been with I would say
why not but other than that whatever
happens happens really those decisions
are up to the big bosses the people who
sign the checks we're open to the idea
but we're not hoping for it right what a
word salad yeah we put a lot in there
but I think that last sentence is the
key of like we're not not hoping for it
we're not expecting it which is kind of
interesting because uh not to be a
horrible person I could see Ned Maybe
not coming back but MJ would probably
play a significant role I feel like I
mean she's the co-lead especially
Marissa Tomei uh rest in peace uh yeah
Zendaya is the co-lead of that series
and I know you're shining down on me
from heaven
so many friends that are named Marissa
Tomei oh she was the hottest Aunt May oh
she was okay well yeah
all right sorry I'm sorry okay so do we
do we um
do we want to see Ned and MJ and the
other students come back no get them out
MJ back Ned gone Flash Thompson back
well now that he doesn't here's my thing
though Jess
he already set up him going Hobgoblin
oh yeah are you are you okay he set it
up yeah when it was like you know my
best friend tried to kill me and
everybody's like Ned Leeds becomes a
hobgoblin yeah and he was like don't
worry I won't kill you maybe that Ned
won't but again the Multiverse is open
that is true that is true that is true
well especially right like so we know
obviously no way home ends with uh MJ
and Ned having their memories wiped they
don't know who Spider-Man is they know
Spider-Man exists but they don't know
it's their buddy Peter right so like
could that have also changed maybe his
relationship to Spider-Man or maybe now
he might view Spider-Man less a friendly
way maybe he's a massive way are you
saying Ned leads his right wing and he
follows Alex Jones AKA Jay Jones
well okay going back to what you said
because I it's like yeah he's leaning
hobgoblin and we could go into the
universe and be like or in different
multiverses and be like he's playing
hobgoblin in this one but he also has
the magic now in the sling ring and he
clearly they kept emptying at his family
knowing magic so would they leave you
think they lean more that way right and
again the premise of this whole episode
is they just lean away right no no Ned
maybe or or no uh MJ so they're open to
it but they're not hoping for it well
and like that that sentence is
interesting we're not hoping for it
could did he mean we're not like waiting
by the phone night and day I I was
afraid to come back I think I've seen a
lot of for whatever reason Jacob battle
odd content this week because I think
he's been doing a lot of press for
whatever reason
mean that this is actually very sent
this is sailing to this point I think
like myself that guy just talks a lot
and I think sometimes his his quotes
seem more meaningful than they are and
he's not 100 getting across what he's
trying to say as in I wasn't insulting
him for doing a lot of press I forgot he
had a vampire movie coming out but it
sounded like I was I don't think like
that quote at the end where he's like
we're not hoping for it I think he's
just not saying it the way I think what
he's saying is I'm not going to sit here
and beg for this job right but I will do
it if they come calling but also Tom
Holland spoils everything so they just
got to keep it as y'all don't know
nothing yeah that's true them
specifically they probably are like we
don't tell them anything you'll know two
weeks before filming starts or something
just be like your calendar is blocked
out for five months and we're not
telling you why we were talking before
uh the show a little bit about like they
had three movies they told us like nice
full Arc they kind of completed High
School Peter yeah right and certainly
Ned is his high school best friend like
maybe the memory white thing gives them
an opportunity to kind of move on to
like a new Peter Parker story that maybe
doesn't involve or involves a lot less
Ned and maybe MJ too I mean
that's so far off to go that route and
when I say that I mean like a story do
we want to see a story that's MJ and Ned
and not Spider-Man no no no I think
there's just they're not oh they're just
not enough yeah yeah yeah the new story
they're telling is a new Spider-Man
story yeah oh okay okay yeah that's the
only way also I mean I don't I don't
know Zendaya if she's like obviously
she's busy she's got a lot of projects I
don't know like where she ranks the
Spider-Man franchise if that's like
priority or if that's like I'd rather be
doing more I don't want to be that
person but like since we're partner's in
it possibly she could be like yeah I'm
doing this also help my partner like I'm
faster thing yeah that's a good point so
I mean I mean knock on wood but they're
still Partners at that point I know
don't say it I just want him to get
married so they can consummate it in the
movie in Spider-Man four people no in
real life no no in the eyes of God no I
want Peter to swing webbing on MJ
Jay's part of the team now okay this is
what a kitchen
no why are you high
five's in your yard you know I'm going
hard
for dinner that high five was the meme
of the black hand and the white
yeah there it is
[Laughter]
Ned showing up in a non-spiderman
property when I say that it's like
because since now he has like uh what
sort of magic I feel like they were
hammering that magic line in with his
family like at least three times we've
seen something like that so is there any
way we could see Ned again probably just
not in the Spider-Man I got the Harkness
show oh my God oh cause Westview was in
New Jersey oh
Westview was in New Jersey they're in
New York but MIT is in Boston is and it
has magic it could go yep roads go
certain places yeah I I like that I also
think you know Sony's got this whole
lineup of of films coming out talking
about creeping the hunter uh Madam Webb
uh El muerto wait I'm sorry is that the
name of it that's a bad bunny uh movie
right jackpot and silk yeah movies yeah
that's right right and so like hey maybe
it's tough to get Tom Holland in one of
those but maybe we could get Jack Jacob
do you think once he goes though he's
gone like vulture like it's like are we
ever gonna see vulture again
in the proper line or yeah in the proper
but also in the MCU it's Michael King
you bringing them back the thing is
Michael King will do anything I love
this is where Keaton's like I'm
everywhere I'm I'm in Spider-Man I'm
Batman I'm here I'm bird man I'm gonna
be Beetlejuice again I'm everywhere I'm
gonna do multiplicity there's gonna be
plenty of me Mr Mom let's go I I like
these ideas is from my flute tutor to my
web shooter okay
stop the conversation just to do that
thank you Tommy anyway so without the
iron spider suit and the help of Tony
Stark are we going to get uh go back to
more street level villains for the next
couple of Spider-Man films well or do
you think the move they make obviously
the movie they were trying to set up
with those awkward more BS post-credit
scenes they want to do a Sinister Six
right yeah right and now there's talk
that Sinister Six could be like
Spider-Man may not even be in that movie
right like that could just be like it's
a weird team up anti-hero thing with
with those villains or if that is the
next right they got Craven coming out
we've already met morbius and Venom and
Carnage and all these other uh scorpion
uh Shockers still out there lurking at a
high school parking lot
um like could that if that's the next
spider if that's the next Tom Holland
appearance we see as a Sinister 16. why
do we need more anti-hero come together
you got the suicide squad because they
don't even be Villas no more the
Thunderbolts and in the Sinister Six
with the worst morbius in God history
and Craven who just is like I'm gonna be
everywhere and then don't look like
Sergey cravenov and then who gonna be
the Rhino okay Michael Mondo is he ain't
doing better call Sauls the show's done
they ain't gonna put no scorpion suit on
him I'm just really upset this is
happening okay I'm very upset because it
doesn't make sense just to have them do
a Sinister Six and it's Sony's right
yeah it's Sony so you you can't get
denaprio
to be part of that to put them together
oh yeah you can't get Kingpin to put
them together unless this is what I
believe that Kevin foggy told Sony just
do what you do we're going to bring them
all in for Secret Wars do what you do oh
okay they all will have a secret rewards
in a little bit and then we can just all
be we don't go separate ways it'd be
great if the portal opened up for Secret
Wars and Michael morvis began to walk
out and someone just shut it down I mean
he's like stand the door they're like oh
here comes vulture oh it's Eddie Brock
oh it's Michael Morris
oh never mind not to change it too much
from off the rails of what we're doing
but do you think they'll pick and choose
which ones of the Sinister Six get to
come into Secret Wars do you think it
wouldn't be all of them it'd be like
three it'd be the ones with the bigger
the higher profile names because again
unfortunately people keep booking Jared
Leto because he's an Academy Award
winner Talent don't exist there but
because he's an Academy Award winner
look nobody thinks Jared Leto was good I
don't I listen I have no I just like the
song Come On Come On the show defend
yourself I just like the song 30 Seconds
to Mars made that's it okay that's all
don't judge me
that's it
you're gonna bring him back because of
course if you bringing back uh Wanda
when she sees Craven who looks just like
her Pietro right it works there's too
many holes in that story it's a lot of
holes in the MCU what'd you guys doing
I do like that though don't you think I
mean we know Secret Wars is slated we
know that's coming at the end John win
his secret Wars
it's phase six right so we got like
three years until Secret Wars we'll see
Spider-Man before that right all right
we'll get a solo spot I don't think
we'll get a
h no no I don't think I don't think
I think we'll get him in other things it
might show up in King Dynasty we might
see him and he'll be like I'm not
Spider-Man can we see him we see him uh
there's a little uh Fantastic Four
Easter egg at the end of uh but that's
all he'll be is just a swing I mean
because you can put anybody in the suit
to swing by should we should we organize
maybe a group trip to one of Jared's
yoga retreats and get some answers for
him no what if I fall for it we'll get
sucked into the cult you'll never see
I'm already in a cult they're not
sponsoring today but okay
in my life
you know what speaking of Cults and
speaking of life I'm a collector oh not
a Bone Collector like that sicko Carrie
elways just kidding great man uh last
night I organized my state quarter
collection and to my dismay Alaska was
missing now I have all 49 state quarters
that matter I'm told that the one from
New Jersey is just a subway token with a
naked lady on it uh no I searched every
nook and cranny of my Mansion so I
remember it I used the Alaskan quarter
to tip my robot Butler Horatio anyway
this morning I was a quarter short and
grog is all get out so you guessed it I
combined a little G fuel together and uh
with some cold brew coffee oh and that's
not the recommended usage oh sorry don't
do that with G fuel but uh you know me I
like to experiment mixing flavors
together soon anyway who knows with a
little G fuel you trash Banks might be
able to escape the dumpster and upgrade
to a dank Alleyway with awning coverage
maybe sneak a peek of a new movie this
weekend open up the exit Escape door oh
holster damn and then they shut it and
they send you back out to the alleyway
where you belong you filthy pieces of
trash anyway check out the Rick and
Morty theme G fuel flavor unstable
portal fluid I know a lot about being
unstable guys and when you can get what
you can get as a tub or in a collector's
box with a shaker cup look at this yeah
look at this I've been drinking it all
episode Zach Zach's got his 10th G fuel
of the day and he's never been healthy
again not the recommended usage fuels I
don't know we're in the boxes that say
not to do 10. John shotgun did you fuel
ones and he was he felt great listen
point being
I'm thinking about Thursday night before
werewolf By Night mixing a few jifu
flavors G fuel has some fun Halloween
theme flavors as well and packs
including a Hocus Focus starter kit and
the candy corn pumpkin bundle say that
three times fast candy corn pumpkin
bundle candy corn pumpkin bundle candy
corn pumpkin balls click the link on the
description and use our code new
rockstars to get 30 off your order
remember you got to use the code new
rockstars to get your 30 off it helps us
it helps you use the code it saves you
some cash and helps us create this
amazing educational show for children
and adults of all ages I heard that code
only works in 49 states Tommy yeah
that's right it works in the 49 states
account if you enter that in New Jersey
they charge you an extra 30 percent but
again I've told you that state doesn't
have Wi-Fi connection someone very smart
in the chat said you can only go to a
Starbucks and log into their free Wi-Fi
in New Jersey the rest of the state yeah
Wired Magazine said uh New Jersey is God
damn
there's been a lot of people throwing in
some super chats uh I think um uh let me
uh Austin long Corey can't really had a
couple in there as soon as I could work
the mouse maybe we'll scroll or we'll
come back to him Tommy uh you had
something you wanted to talk about yeah
it's uh
it's time for mandatory fun oh no
there's the traffic yes
ah it's mandatory fun this the segment
where I gather my three best friends in
the whole wide world and I make them
have a little fun with me it's the
segment so beloved that we play
the graphic that is Coveted hit it again
it's
it's the segment that's so hip we play
that She-Hulk clip hit it
oh oh did he hit the you had the clip
queued up okay not to hold that nothing
yes it's the segment that's such a trip
we once again play the Seahawk clip whoa
Tommy I won't be stopped
oh I love this segment from my swaddler
to my howler okay
what we didn't tell Jay about mandatory
fun yes that's right we are back with
She-Hulk predictions let's take a look
at the standings okay we don't have a
Graphic for the standings I'm told I'm
in first place oh okay
um anyway I I heard the chat's doing
awful Jessica's in second Zach's in
third uh Brandon's in fourth and the
chat is in the distant fifth uh so Jay
you're gonna have to predict for Brandon
today okay okay so we have three
questions let everybody go around how
many times do we think Luke Jacobson the
designer will insult She-Hulk slash
Jennifer in this episode oh fun in like
a fun caddy kind of yeah not like not
like your parents deserve to die or
something like just like hey uh your
butt looks big in that suit I made you
yeah
you probably live in a dumpster like
someone who watches an online streaming
show in chats okay yeah I I went low on
this I said just once I think he
obviously got in a bunch of barbs the
first time we met uh his character but
now she's wearing his outfit so he's
gonna like the way she looks I don't
think he'll be oh you don't know black
gay fashion designers
72
we're gonna count this as each
individual remark so if he's like that
hair those feet right things like that
yeah oh my God uh we redeemed the chat
which was to make a rant and you get
like 60 seconds to make a ramp I think
it should be Jake yeah Jay I think you
should do you have a topic you're
feeling strongly about you yeah okay
come on giving out a god who's ahead of
my life first and foremost I want to say
this if you are mad at a black mermaid
that is not even real a half fish if you
are a grown man yes complain about why
my fishing red hair we need to check
your search history sir yes
browser you can be okay with a half fish
dude without a fish tank saying it's a
trap but a black elf is a problem to you
y'all was still mad when it was possible
that LaShonda Lynch was gonna be double
07. the perfect job for a black woman is
a spy okay she can break into anything
she wants to ask Jessica she knows how
to get into men's phones without even us
knowing but again back to you again
and half brain dance dudes some of them
hurting me you move me your black girl
and she's running water she wouldn't be
black I guess she would cause she's not
[ __ ] real oh wow I'd be willing to
just run that back if we want to just
keep having Jay do my rat okay can you
just do your 10.
I think the only the only done said to
that is uh we should have tried to get
more than 100 bucks out of the chat yeah
yeah I ran to that quality and passion
yeah let's be honest both ramps were
equally amazing but Jay's was slightly
better by a hundred percent uh all right
real quick before we I did finally get
the amounts to work and so uh uh thank
you Mikey cheers uh mgz pnw uh Moda
awesome uh and everybody uh with in the
super chat we'll maybe come back and
answer some of the show Corey sent out
some super chats early on we appreciate
that he is from New Jersey which is
unfortunate but uh well but he does work
on Marvel he's one of the good ones
projects so yeah we can uh thank him for
that now I didn't want to out you Corey
I hope I didn't do that uh for uh what
you do for a living let's just say he's
a carpenter he paints houses like Robert
De Niro and the Irishman uh okay so how
many times will Luke Jacobson insult
She-Hulk Jennifer Jay says seven Jessica
uh I said zero Jessica said zero I went
one I said three you still don't think
we're gonna see him I don't think we're
gonna see him oh I was told he's back
for another at least one more episode
right it could be the last episode right
uh nope too late you already said zero
minus three so you can't steal my answer
uh
you and Brandon have a different
relationship than you and I have what's
mine is yours or what's yours is mine
and what's mine is mine
and I'm a little scoundrel uh
uh take my heart but never take my
answers how many total minutes will pug
be in the show
I miss him like crazy and we're gonna do
this uh we're gonna round up or down so
if it's like 7 15 that goes down to
seven if it's 7 45 you know how rounding
works that goes up to eight
okay because it felt like in those first
couple episodes when she was at the law
firm it felt like he was going to be a
big part of the show we kind of missed
in the last couple episodes I I think I
went I went two minutes because I think
he could he could come in just for a
scene or two but deliver some fun lines
two minutes Jennifer you know I'm
getting a new hat from the guy at the
corner store do you want a Milky Way bar
gone if that is read the description
uh if that's written in the script they
need to hire this right yeah okay uh
okay so you said two more minutes
Jessica what are you saying I think I
said seven I can't remember okay
uh I'm
I said six I said six thanks for keeping
me honest because this is the
penultimate and with the situation with
uh Josh
I think the beginning of the episode
will start in the uh office in the law
office yes yes Queen uh I think the
beginning of the episode I think
probably three minutes at the most I
don't think we're getting a lot of them
I think we'll get him more in episode
nine okay yeah okay
I forget that this is like the over like
if you go over you're automatically out
so I'm gonna say I'm changing mine to
13. 13.
okay well no I'll do oh
God I hate that going over is like
you're automatically out listen the
answer has to be in the slack by 11 59
tonight you can change your answers up
to 11.59 I'll say 10.
great uh so that's everybody we got
everyone here so finally thank you let
me just real quick
will there be a post-credits scene bonus
points for predicting what the
post-credits scene is I'll start since
everyone else has a kind of uh you know
I've got the advantage of listening to
other people's predictions yes and I'll
tell you why this is a cat Corey Road
directed episode she has post-credit
scenes oh oh Tommy's done some homework
okay yeah I don't mean to give I don't
mean Trade Secrets but she's directing
this episode she loves post credit post
credit scene is gonna be this Todd
Todd here did you do it the job's done
sir I told you excellent well so Todd is
not the top level
there's so much working for Todd Todd's
got a guy Todd's got a guy okay yeah and
that sets up the final episode of the
reveal that's right interesting okay
it's so funny because I said the exact
same thing on slack oh I guess you can
take mine and I can't take his did you
say that yeah I said the same thing I
said you just said it would be Todd yeah
I said a specific action type oh my God
we can we can go what do you think Todd
will be doing let's go to the tape here
[Laughter]
no but there but if there was it would
be tough so first of all you said there
wouldn't be yeah
three six yes and it's Todd on the phone
with a mystery person okay so we both
said it was Todd so do you get extra
points let's hold a poll here so Josh is
Todd is the um the guy that went on this
feed date that's like you're quite the
special oh yeah Josh is the guy that
actually got her blood I think it I
think it is a post credit scene and I
think officially Tim Blake Nelson shows
up oh I think the leader finally shot
you got a triple ooh out of that you got
everyone else out of the paddle to go
do another ring he's confirmed for
Captain America that's why I think
that's why because when they first when
they first did it in episode three
somebody's trying to steal her blood
okay everyone's like it could be
titanium no who else would want the
Hulk's blood and we've been been
bringing back characters from the movies
that were not official MCU movies I was
I said it on my channel I was like it
would not surprise me if it's the leader
that wants it then we started seeing
Intelligentsia we started seeing this
whole King who else really wants Hulk
blood the leader and Jay what channel is
that yeah uh you can find me on
youtube.com Jay Washington a0 I'm there
every time that the show happens talking
about it Jay is the only person that's a
guest is allowed to plug their other
stuff if Coy ever tries again he gets
thrown out
this is not our official role I would
have only done it if they didn't yeah
thank you I love you back please find
Jay find Jay on all sorts
I actually I went to the boring answer I
mean I'm swayed now that you mentioned
the cat core thing uh I said no no post
credit scene never given us one in a
couple weeks it would be kind of crazy
to just show it up randomly on the eight
the seventh episode
just disappear for four or three and
then come back back is kind of can't
they both have Todd I assume that's both
of us and the resounding yes I think
that's because people like you better as
a person but no I'm right on this issue
Tommy is in charge of the predictions
going forward so Tommy can whatever he
says I'm with all right now normally
mandatory fun would end at this point
but today's Wednesday you know what that
means
it's and or day can I have the
microphone please oh yeah okay okay I
know some of you are not watching
Wikileaks uh which leads me to believe
that some of you aren't watching Andor
big mistake
I love this show for my blue milk zipper
to my hyperdrive Ripper okay it's Star
Wars like you've never seen before it
mixes elements of spycraft cops and
robbers and even a dash of the wire you
know there's a there's some signaling
that like the cops might be coming
around we gotta bang on some posts there
is a little bit of the wire on the show
okay trust me Jay I know Baltimore drug
culture I've I've been to Baltimore
three times anyway how did they say this
ball more I'm taking crap straight out
of the water in Baltimore all right
don't worry about me no no no you're
right
I want the Star Wars character with a
Baltimore accent what kind of things
would they say a fire like Faith
disturbing find your lack of fight
disturbance why does your Baltimore
sound like he's from Louisiana no no my
Louisiana Ball come for down for that
gumbo
okay we are cooking alligator tail today
on the break room
now our Baltimore we Old Bay sauce on
the crabs
doesn't care if you've never seen an
episode of Star Wars or if you have a
tattoo or jar jar on your twin moons
okay this show is for the people for the
people for the Rebellion you want a
grown man moving back in with his
overbearing Mom it's on Android you want
cousin Richie hands from the bear as a
hunky Rebel Freedom Fighter it's on
Andor this is Star Wars content for
adults can you handle it and as weird as
that might sound to some of you sips it
works there's plenty of Ewoks and
different droids for kids on other shows
hell Grog was gonna be back in a couple
months we're sure you trash bags just
keep that up in your dumpster
[Applause]
frog Edge they got gay frogs
we're only on week three of andors
ketchup it's not too late it's not being
a sip for dragons and dwarves and fools
and ORS where all the players are
getting together we got droids we got
fast ships fast ships fast enough for
you old man
fast enough for you old man so join me
on Wednesdays and make it an Andor day
so we can talk about it on the break
room with the Sickness
no cap
no cat someone said you won't find this
on Wookie weeks and that's true that's
true
yeah that was well said Tommy uh but for
real everybody should be watching
Android that show's really really good I
don't think it's very popular right now
none of our content is super popular
about it uh you shouldn't just watch it
to help out new rockstars you should
watch it to help out yourself enjoy it
it's a good show I'm sorry all kidding
aside obviously I'm playing a character
nothing like my real Persona on this
show if you met me in real life you'd be
like wow he's so gentle he's so
dignified but when I'm on here I
recognize just how much garbage watches
this content and I want you to watch and
Order Enlighten yourself class it up
climb up out of your trash bins get to
the penthouse go from the dumpster to
the penthouse by watching Andor elevate
your mind
no no I need to ask this what's the PIN
if you're in the dumpster it's one of
those smart garbage cans where you hover
your hand over it and it goes okay cool
okay I don't like that you two are on
the same page
you better believe I am
you better believe I am of course I'm
sure
Jessica
um uh shout out to everybody uh the
chats uh love and Tommy's rant of course
and shout out to everybody that was
super chat today ammo saying I'm uh I'm
doing Cyril car and cosplay all this uh
generic white dudes kind of look alike
to you don't we uh Emma uh mgz p and w
thank you uh Rupert Jamison where do I
apply to work for Jay oh do you need any
employees I will say Jay is a hit in the
chat today Jay's been getting a lot of
love first of all thank you to everybody
in the chat I appreciate y'all secondly
uh I ain't got no job so I'm here so I'm
gonna wake up
oh yeah I am on yes I'm on American
Gigolo on Showtime
and catch my character Luther in
episodes two and three and I will be
back again in the season finale episode
eight so if you're watching this do me a
favor tweet out we want more Luther on
American Gigolo and American Gigolo
season two cause we ain't got an order
for season two yet because I want to
come back so
watch that show bring them back uh TD
Jones Thank You Perry Perry Clemens no
relation no relationship okay no wait I
think we said yes as a bit but okay yeah
okay he's here for the New Jersey
slander okay well he might be related to
Tommy in that case I don't know uh uh
Mikey cheers saying in Deadpool 3 what
if we get Deadpool to convince the actor
Hugh Jackman to pose as his Wolverine
uh that's definitely fourth wall
breaking that'd be a lot of fun I like
that idea uh mgc pnw coming back Jess
let's go out next time you're in the
Seattle area
yeah maybe it'll be a plutonic Meetup
don't make Tommy upset a very plutonic
Meetup plutonic people like nuclear
you wouldn't like me when I'm cramping
up I'm cramping it up stop my entire
left side's cramping up what's this
tingling okay we gotta get out of here
before Tommy dies uh most awesome I
think Dr Doom is in wakanda forever we
talked about that yesterday Jay what's
your opinion he absolutely is he's the
reason everything is happening I know
he's absolutely the reason why you see
the people going on the ships thing is I
can't trust Jay because he when I say he
can't trust J's Jay is ahead of
everything he knows everyone knows
everything so he's probably just
spoiling he said he has eight friends in
the MCU one of them could be Tina cuerta
we don't know one of them could be nice
to do I'm not friends with him no but I
am friends with Monica Rambo oh okay
we are in Chiraq together we're gonna
Spike Lee Jordan sign right together I
think she's pregnant right yeah she is
could you congratulate Jay on there
yo we know it's not my baby it's your
hood Rambo
Aquaman Aquaman
[Laughter]
[Applause]
there's a megapaint of why okay uh okay
I think that that that's enough yeah I
feel good we've done some damage
287 beats a minute right now I think we
should be good we better get out of here
yes thank you all so much for joining us
again reminder we'll be doing a big
werewolf by night uh special show on
Friday come back for that we'll be doing
weird Halloween themed episodes
throughout the month yeah you probably
were going to see us in some costumes
sometime next week uh some fun costumes
we've already got that bit planned I
might go method and sleep in a dumpster
tonight to see what it's like to be a
viewer of this show
okay uh but uh display with Tommy says
we appreciate everybody thank you Jay
Washington thank you so much yes yes
look I've been waiting like I said I've
been waiting but everybody was like we
saw Jay lived there I've been living out
here since 2015. it was it was a
miscommunication but now we know we've
mended defenses
don't look at each other's eyes
review again
that's because she always calls me
yeah thank you for watching everybody
have a great rescue for your week and
what she helped tonight we'll be talking
about it tomorrow watch and or you
stamps
[Music]